[Musica]
Sono Fabiana Andreani Ho 41 anni sono
nata in Umbria viva Milano mi occupo di
orientamento e formazione L'ho fatto per
più di 10 anni in azienda in business
School nella appunto nella città
menghina e attualmente mi occupo di
content Creation lo faccio sui miei
canali Social mi trovate su Instagram
tiktok LinkedIn come Fabiana manager ho
creato questo lavoro da zero e si è
sostituito la mia professione Ecco io in
azienda sono stata per tanti anni ed ero
felice devo dire che pensavo di non
poter raggiungere di più immaginatemi è
ero come Come adesso solo con i capelli
chatouche il taer con i colori neutri
parlavo in maniera abbastanza compassata
introduceva degli inglesismi perché a
Milano si usa così ecco Pensavo di non
essere appunto in grado di desiderare
altro poi
improvvisamente una piccola faglia nella
diga ha fatto esplodere una me stessa
molto più autentica sicuramente creativa
sicuramente sopra le righe numerosa e
folle Come direbbe D'Annunzio nella
poesia l'onda vi invito a leggerla
perché io mi sono ritrovata in questa
ecco ho realizzato questa professione da
zero adesso ho usato i social per dare
voce A chi aveva bisogno Ecco se mi
trovate sui social io do consigli sul
lavoro Ascolto le persone con un piglio
che non è quello della maestra che ti
guarda dall'altro ma è proprio un modo
di mettersi a disposizione di di empatia
mi scrivete in dm vi rispondo
Naturalmente se mi chiedete di leggervi
la busta paga non è la mia competenza
però un consiglio su come orientare il
vostro futuro professionale lo faccio e
quindi direste Ok va bene tutto Mi sono
realizzata quindi non ho più bisogno di
niente e invece no perché la cosa di cui
nessuno parlo perlomeno se ne parla poco
eh di quanto è difficile cambiare io
adesso non faccio l'alzata di mano
solita de tedex in cui vi chiedo quante
persone vogliono cambiare lavoro o
quante persone sono infelici nel lavoro
che fanno ma immagino che tra voi che mi
Guardate siamo in tanti Ecco siamo siete
nel senso alti e bassi Ecco e poi
nessuno parla di quanto è difficile
cambiare e uscire dagli schemi ahimè
questo è vero cioè è difficile quando
siamo diversi ma è difficile anche
quando semplicemente siamo donne madri e
abbiamo un lavoro Io questo l'ho fatto
non ho fatto nulla di male in realtà ho
cambiato lavoro però ho creato una
carriera che mi assomigliava dopo aver
messo al mondo un figlio e questo ha
causato tanti dispiaceri questo nelle
persone che avevano aspettative su di me
mia mamma diceva Io ero contenta avevi
un lavoro che ti portava alla pensione
avevi un figlio quindi perché ti sei
messa a fare altro Ecco questo pensate
c'è qualcosa di cui non si dà voce ma è
difficile cambiare e allora io adesso vi
vorrei portare proprio anche a un
percorso per capire il cambiamento da un
punto di vista sostenibile Nel senso che
siamo abituati a pensare il cambiamento
come qualcosa che rompe che distrugge
che è doloroso ovviamente c'è un prima e
c'è un dopo c'è un momento in cui
dobbiamo inviare la domanda per le
nostre dimissioni c'è un momento in cui
dobbiamo dire no o il momento in cui
dobbiamo partire Però il cambiamento È
un processo che può andare avanti molto
nel tempo di solito con che cosa inizia
il cambiamento ecco il cambiamento
inizia con un disagio io faccio molti
gesti Ma perché vi voglio un po'
svegliare quindi non non non state a
pensare a guardare il cellulare Mi
raccomando Seguite il cambiamento inizia
con un disagio una sensazione di
insofferenza e attenzione Io penso che
l'avete provato C'è anche una sensazione
di trappola Noi abbiamo paura in quella
sensazione di disagio di non trovare una
via d'uscita Pensateci l'avremmo provato
sto in quel lavoro non riesco a cambiare
non vedo una l'uscita in realtà è una
sensazione illusoria illusoria quella
sensazione ricordatevelo perché in
quella sensazione di disagio Noi siamo
anche potenzialmente in ascolto In
quell'ascolto Possiamo valutare varie
possibilità nel mio caso io lavoravo in
azienda avevo iniziato a fare
divulgazione sui social c'è stato un
momento molto lungo nella quale io ho
fatto entrambe avevo una partita IVA e
un contratto a tempo indeterminato
lavoravo 16 ore al giorno e portavo
avanti due progetti questo perché perché
stavo valutando varie alternative e
queste varie alternative è bene
valutarle anche quando siamo in un porto
sicuro perché non è detto che dobbiamo
fare startup e lanciarci nei pitch
andare a a raccogliere investimenti
senza avere le spalle coperte le spalle
coperte ci devono essere soprattutto
quando come nel mio caso avevi già un
figlio 41 anni un muto acceso Ecco
questo lungi da me appunto dirvi delle
cose appunto che non mi appartengono in
quel momento di osservazione possiamo
trovare delle alternative alternative
che ci piacciono alternative che in
realtà magari non ci piacciono le
possiamo sperimentare ma avere le spalle
coperte dopodiché cosa succede c'è un
momento di transizione Ovviamente un
momento nella quale dobbiamo prendere
una decisione in quella decisione in
realtà può essere dolorosa perché
sicuramente c'è una rinuncia Però vi do
anche la chiave che vi deve guidare deve
essere una sensazione di sollievo le
cose con quella scelta devono in qualche
modo darvi qualcosa di piacevole non
sono per i salti nel buio non fate i
salti nel buio perché una piccola luce
la dovete vedere se non riuscite a
vedere quella luce dovete attendere
raccogliere più informazioni avere
magari Maggiore consapevolezza del
momento finché non avrete il momento
adatto Poi magari c'è chi dice Sì vabbè
ma così non le faccio mai le cose Oh ho
detto però che dovete essere voi in
grado di sostenere quel quindi non
fatevi influenzare dagli altri le cose
non si fanno tanto per farle perché poi
appunto possiamo subire delle
conseguenze che magari non siamo in
grado di gestire Quindi io vi dico
Aspettate finché non trovate quel tipo
di luce Dopodiché Ahimè il momento può
durare anche tanto come vi ho detto non
è detto che noi dobbiamo per forza
cambiare lavoro tinger i capelli di blu
abbandonare quella che è la nostra
sicurezza magari non lo so crearci
un'altra vita in un'altra città possono
essere anche piccole cose può essere
anche per esempio al lavoro imparare a
Calcare la mano Ecco io una cosa che
consiglio spesso alle persone quando si
trovano in un lavoro che non piace e
magari non hanno ancora la possibilità
per abbandonarlo o non hanno
un'alternativa è quello di Calcare la
mano nel senso cercare nelle cose che
facciamo di spostare un pochino più il
limite magari avendo l'accortezza di
cercare di farlo più vicino a quello che
ci piace può essere modificare un
processo modificare unattivit
creare magari degli orari diversi o
delle abitudini diverse come nel mio
caso quando inizi questo processo di
transizione arrivai un giorno al lavoro
con le mie punte sciatusc bionde tinte
di Rosa Quindi avevo cercato un po' di
Calcare la mano in quel mondo delle
Corporate così rigido Dopodiché in
questo caso il momento del distacco
avviene avviene a un certo punto che non
ce la facciamo più a fare le due cose ma
anche se non dovesse avvenire vi dico va
bene tutto in quel caso perché deve
stare bene a voi se il momento di
transizione dura un anno e mezzo come
nel mio caso Dura 2 anni o magari non
non c'è una transizione netta Ma magari
c'è un affiancamento va bene Siete voi
in quel momento a decidere a decidere
come sulla base di quello che vi fa
stare sereni in quel momento io sono per
questo non sono per la spinta che deve
essere in qualche modo dilaniante
Dopodiché in qualche modo se la
transizione avviene se c'è un prima e se
c'è un dopo Avremo anche un momento
nella quale Sì come nel mio caso adesso
ho una partita IVA faccio creazione di
contenuti sui miei canali Social non
sono figlia di nessuno non ho un marito
che mi mantiene quindi ogni tanto mi
sveglio la mattina e dico Oddio Madonna
Io vivo a Milano Porca miseria ce la
farò a tirare avanti oppure dei momenti
in cui come qui dico che bello Io sono
qui su questo palco per una cosa che ho
iniziato veramente da zero cercando
semplicemente di aiutare le persone
attraverso i social quindi ci sono
questi alti bassi nel momento in cui
vi sposterete nell'altra direzione in
cui ci sarà il primo e il dopo ci
saranno dei momenti tanti nella quale
rimpiangerete il passato come vi ho
detto prima o nella quale come anche nel
mio caso a volte non si riesce a vedere
il futuro vi dicono di fare de business
plan vi dicono di fare delle ipotesi di
quello che possono essere un piano di
sviluppo ma a volte anche come nel mio
caso io realmente non riesco a vedere un
futuro ma forse è anche una questione
tipica della mia generazione dei
millenni della generazione Z Sì ho 41
anni sono un millennial i millennial
hanno ormai 40 anni quelli più vecchi
quindi non sono più dei ragazzini siamo
un po' una generazione che è nata con il
benessere che poi è stata abbandonata in
queste illusioni che poi non sono state
tradotte in una realtà Quindi quello che
vorrei adesso invitarvi a fare nella
transizione è non fermarvi sul passato o
dire non riesco a vedere il futuro ma
fermarvi su quello che sapete fare sulle
vostre competenze si dice che il nostro
contratto a tempo indeterminato siamo
noi ed è vero perché le persone quando
perdono il lavoro a una certa età magari
un pochino più elevata non riescono a
reinserirsi perché molto spesso non
hanno investito nella loro formazione
sono persone che sono rimaste lì
immobili a fare sempre lo stesso lavoro
sempre in quel tipo di azienda Quindi è
chiaro che se vai in un contesto che non
conosci Non hai delle competenze quindi
le competenze che hai quello che sai
fare è quello che ti farà trovare il
nuovo lavoro ed è quello che a me ogni
mattina mi fa dire Guarda Fabiana in
realtà tu non stai investendo su
qualcosa di futile tu stai investendo su
te stessa su delle competenze stai
sviluppando un lavoro che non è
solamente creare contenuti ma è fare
orientamento fare progetti di consulenza
con le aziende eh aiutare le aziende a
raggiungere quelle che sono le nuove
generazioni e offrire loro delle
opportunità di lavoro quindi non mi
sembra così banale non mi sembra che sei
una persona così che non ha questo
futuro che incerto quindi Quindi da
questo punto di vista vi dico
concentratevi sulle competenze le
competenze vi aiuteranno Poi visto che
il mio discorso vuole essere breve
Quindi vorrei anche abitu avviarmi verso
la conclusione non avendo slide tutto
bene senza slide Siete ancora in grado
Ok benissimo perché lo dico perché senza
slide è come vedere un video di tiktok
senza sottotitoli ormai le persone
skippo subito quindi bisogna mettere un
po' di
disclaimer Per quanto riguarda vivere
l'incertezza io come vivo incertezza
come ho come ho deciso Cioè ho deciso Sì
di lasciare il lavoro a tempo
indeterminato in azienda Corporate se
poi Guardate su LinkedIn vedete anche le
aziende dove ho lavorato con una frase
che in realtà mi è stata detta da una
persona che non mi sarei aspettata mia
madre mia madre a 70 anni ha lavorato 44
anni penso nella stessa azienda quindi
mi sarei aspettata da una decisione del
genere lascio indeterminato per la
partita IVA qualcosa di diverso Invece
mia madre mi ha detto provaci e io in
realtà ci sto provando e in questo ci
sto provando sto mettendo insieme quello
che è il beneficio del dubbio ma anche
la leggerezza del gioco Cioè io sto
giocando Io come diceva prima il dottor
calvarese Io veramente mi diverto a fare
questo lavoro Ho creato un lavoro che mi
appartiene e mi fa veramente star bene
ogni giorno e in questo ci sto provando
Ho realizzato anche un'altra cosa che
non sto deludendo nessuno non sto
deludendo me stessa perché sto
investendo nelle mie competenze non sto
andando a RAM in strade così
semplicemente perché mi sono impazzita
un giorno quando ancora ero in maternità
E soprattutto non sto deludendo nessuno
gli altri Quindi in fin dei conti Io
sono riuscita ad esprimere me stessa e
quindi sì questo va bene tutto vorrei
concludere con una poesia di khil Gibran
molto breve Spero che me la ricordi
perché non ho nulla in mano quindi
adesso che mi assista alla memoria la
poesia recita così eh non amare mezzi
amanti non trattenere mezzi amici e non
vivere una mezza vita e non morire di
mezza morte perché la metà è un momento
di mera incapacità Ma tu sei capace per
te di esistere Non a metà perché sei un
tutto che esiste per sé ed è capace di
vivere un'intera vita non una mezza vita
grazie
ancora